here at Max Tech we've been using
anchors Chargers and products for years
now since they're honestly the best
we've tested just look at my own
purchase history over the years buying
various anchor products because of their
reputation for being high quality and
reliable so an anchor reached out to
partner up with us on this video showing
off their new Gan Prime Multi-Device
fast Chargers we couldn't say no so
before we get into the details about
each one of these Chargers including
this one which is incredibly unique and
creative I've got to talk about what all
of these have in common they all use
gallium nitride Gan technology which
gives them higher power capacity making
them very fast and efficient while being
Ultra Compact and portable compared to
other chargers since these are
constructed using anchors exclusive
stacked internal structure to reduce
size by up to 53 percent compared to
Apple's chargers they all have multiple
ports so there's less E-Waste since you
need fewer Chargers and since they use
anchors power power IQ 4.0 technology
that detects the power requirements of
your devices and dynamically distributes
power in real time like for higher
wattage devices simultaneously anchor
says they save enough energy to power
Hawaii for 30 days and because of this
Dynamic power distribution feature which
adjusts every three minutes and releases
extra power output for other devices it
can charge up to 30 minutes faster
compared to other charges that don't
have this feature and finally the active
Shield 2.0 technology intelligently
monitors temperature and adjusts power
output to protect your devices so you
don't have to worry about any issues
with fast charging at night and now with
all that new tech out of the way let me
show you how cool and unique each one of
these charges are starting with this one
the Anker 733 power bank Gan Prime power
core 65 watt and by the way you'll find
the links to all these down in the
description below now what makes this
one really unique is that it's got
prongs built in so it seems like a
simple charger that you plug into the
wall but it actually doubles as a
battery bank which you can take with you
on the go with a nice little charging
indicator built into the button it's
rated for 10 000 milliamp hours which is
literally over three times the amount of
battery that's in the new iPhone 14 pro
but since it's a 65 watt charger you can
also get full speed fast charging on the
new M2 MacBooks or of course plug in
both your iPhone and MacBook or maybe
your iPad and as a little bonus it also
packs an extra USB a port as well for
whatever else you need to charge or
power and my favorite feature of all is
that you can simply plug it into the
wall without needing a power cable so
it'll recharge the battery pack while
your devices are still plugged in and of
course if you don't need the battery
Bank itself you can just leave it
plugged into the wall so it'll be topped
off when you do need it now if you
simply just want a super portable 65
watt charger here's the ink anchor 735
charger Gan Prime 65 watt which is
incredibly compact Ashley 53 smaller
than Apple's slower 61 watt charger and
what's nice about it is that it's very
slim so it won't interfere with other
wall plugs and it even comes with a
silicon stabilizer in case your wall
plugs are worn out and loose and for
portability it also features foldable
prongs and just like the first one I
showed you it's got up to 65 watts of
charging power but if you want to go all
out they've also got the Anker 747
charger Gan Prime 150 watt which offers
up to a massive 150 watts of power which
can fast charge four different devices
at once and the crazy thing is that it's
38 smaller than the original Apple 140
watt charger except of course it's got
four ports instead of one next up we
have the super unique and thoughtfully
designed anchor 615 USB power strip Gan
Prime 65 watt which comes plugged into
itself like this to offer infinite power
I'm just kidding it simply makes it
incredibly portable now you might be
wondering why the cable looks so short
for a power strip well that's because
this unique rubber shroud conceals the
rest of the cable to make it look really
clean and portable and lifting it up
reveals the full length three foot cable
now just like the other two it offers 65
watts of charging power across the two
USBC ports and USB a port which can
charge a 14 inch MacBook Pro in just 37
minutes however this power strip also
comes with not one but two AC Outlets so
you can plug in whatever else your heart
desires making it perfect for travel now
the Anker 727 charging station Gan Prime
100 watt takes this to the next level
being incredibly capable considering how
thin and compact it is this one comes
with a very high quality five foot power
cord and the power station supplies up
to 100 watts of power that can charge a
16 inch MacBook Pro to 50 in 43 minutes
or you can split up the charge by for
example supplying 65 watts to your
MacBook while giving 30 to your iPad
across a total of two USBC ports two USB
a ports and two AC outlets right on top
so this one is perfect if you want to
charge your laptop your iPhone and other
products like your Apple watch and
airpods all at the same time now the
crazy and unique thing about discharging
station is that it's so thin that it
seems impossible to plug in a full power
plug but the genius is over at anchor
engineered the outlets themselves to
extend and protrude out when something
gets plugged into it which is super
creative and clever and it allows it to
stay as thin as possible for traveling
and it's even got a little light on it
that turns blue to show you when it's
outputting between 90 and 100 watts of
power and then finally we have the
anchor 737 charger again prime 120 watt
which is similar to the 735 but instead
of 65 watts of power IT Supplies 120
watts which is super impressive
considering the compact design which is
39 smaller than Apple's much slower 96
watt charger just like the other one it
comes with a silicone stabilizer two
usb-c ports and a USB a port except this
one obviously outputs a lot more power
so it's meant to be able to fast charge
your MacBook and another device like
your iPhone or iPad at the same time so
I've got to admit I was pleasantly
surprised by the build quality of all
these new Gan Prime products from Anker
and you can find the link to all of them
in the description and pinned comment
below once again thank you for anchor
for partnering up with us on this video
and if you're interested in any of these
let me know which one you're thinking
about buying in the comments thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
foreign